all right people looks like we got
ourselves another
justice league little snippet of a
trailer february 14th valentine's day
the official trailer comes out we're in
my superman shirt today which has a hole
in it
oh for the nipple i laser blasted it
laser nips
why don't you just let me make my joke
first instead of
coming in to say your stupid comment
yes [ __ ] like that yg
wow
[Music]
oh whoa damn
that is cooler than anything
out of that justice league movie we got
before
look at this shot look at the men that
is there oh there's got to be gifts
going around by this
point i need this gift look at that
someone give it clip it
send it he just shoots in the frame just
like comes in they're like
hair fly oh this is gonna make the
demand for the follow-up to man of steel
to come back this looks great this this
looks like
you know when youtubers put together
awesome fan edits a black suit superman
that's right but a
real movie production quality version of
that bust out those color correction
skills
damn that is a beautiful yeah and it
like to
you know all the hype around you know
the expansion on black suit superman and
doing superman story justice like that
looks
absolutely sinister how long is this
that is like one point eight seconds
it's the new thing we only show you a
second and a half
seconds that is so cool and let's see
that works though
like weirdly enough godzilla and this
i'm like show uh
one badass image and maybe that's worth
more than an entire oh
that was so cool his hair looks so good
his hair that's he's got this real looks
like
it looks like classics on the big
screen is that haircut and the music is
beautiful it's brilliant so what else
happens in this trailer
you know steppenwolf he waves that axe
and
oh i guess he's summoning darkseid or
something that's what's that
john it's a big old omega symbol god
damn right that's the omega symbol with
a bunch of
frilly stuff around that's right no zack
snyder's omega symbol that's right it's
even yeah
the greeks had in mind why why just have
the horseshoe shape no no
no we gotta confuse people and make this
like a metal album title
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below for that awesome piece of piece of
gift beauty you guys can't see but
you know greg has got see now i want i
wanted to preserve in case i got the
nipple chill moment for later and then
you just like i
i was gonna have my prepared sentence
and then you just always
come in and interrupt like oh i got a
thought let me not wait for greg to
mother effer subscribe
blah blah